Welcome everyone. Good afternoon. Oh,
welcome to another exciting
talks at Google event.
And this is the second in our ongoing
series of speakers from us that work with
Stanford's Center for the advanced
study in the behavioral sciences.
And so today we're very thrilled
to host Eric Klinenberg.
He's back to the toxic Google program.
Having Spoken,
I'm in New York a few years back as well.
And without any further ado,
please join me in welcoming
America to Google. Thanks.
Okay.
Ah, thank you cliff. Thank you all
for being here during lunch. Um,
the food is really good
if you haven't had it yet,
you probably know it better than I do,
but, um, it's, it's great to be here. Um,
can you hear me okay? Is this fine? Um,
so typically these days when I go to
give a talk and bring up modern romance,
everyone wants to know in
advance is as z is coming.
And um, you know, look,
when you write a book
with someone like Aziz,
you learn to play the second
fiddle. So I'm fine with that. Um,
and the answer is usually, you know,
I don't know. He could show up.
So if anybody comes through this
door in the next few minutes just,
well let's all look and see if it
turns out to be as disease. Um,
it would be a little bit of a stretch
for him because he's hosting Saturday
night,
Saturday night live this weekend.
You might've heard that it's the
the day after the inauguration.
So it's a high pressure
gig. Let's say. Oh nope.
It's not as easy as well the children
next time someone comes in we'll,
I'll look and we'll see if it's
disease. It might be as, okay.
What I want to do today is actually,
I'm not talking exclusively about modern
romance, as interesting as that is,
I want to talk a little bit more generally
about the sociology of connection,
some patterns that are worth
sharing. Um, and um, and I,
and I want to do it by,
by talking to you both about this book I
wrote a few years ago called going solo
about the rise of people living alone
in the world and also then about the
research that went into modern romance.
And you'll see a common
thread emerge through them.
And the way I want to get into this is,
um,
by telling you about a magazine story
that came out a few years ago from the
Atlantic, which is a really
serious and wonderful publication,
always very provocative. Um,
definitely not a fake news publication,
a real news publication. Um, the
tends to go very deep and, um,
they,
they put this story on the cover a few
years ago and I don't know if you can
read it clearly,
but the covers stories is
Facebook making us lonely.
And that's a question,
but as you probably can tell already,
it's also an accusation, right? Um,
of course the answer to the cover
story is not know otherwise.
It wouldn't be on the cover.
Right. And even if it was no,
the deed is already done because you've
associated Facebook with loneliness in
your mind.
And if I say don't think of an elephant,
I've undermined myself
in that very way. So, um,
you here at Google need to know that the
story about whether Facebook is making
us lonely is not just
a story about Facebook.
Google is also part of the story because
the broader question that this article
is taking up and it's a question that
many people in the world these days are
raising is,
is this new culture that we are creating
and that you are creating as much if
not more than anyone.
Uh,
where we spend all this time with our
screens on a amazing apps and programs and
other, um, you know, features that, uh,
entertain us and help us be productive
and connect us and all kinds of
interesting ways to people we'd
never otherwise be connected to our,
all those things at the end of the day,
making us more lonely and more
isolated than ever before.
I'm sure all of you in this room have
heard a version of this question, right?
I mean,
it's a big problem that we're trying to
solve and the author of this piece in
the Atlantic,
which is a place that everybody who's got
ideas and rights wants to be says yes.
Uh, the claim in this article is that
we have never been lonelier. Okay.
We are now, ironically, we were living
through the loneliest age and history and,
okay,
so that's a deep and serious
journalistic publication.
In my own field we've had
similar kinds of debates and um,
I'm going to,
this is,
I'm going to talk to you about the study
that was in the American sociological
review, uh, on social
isolation in American life.
Now I know that you're all regular readers
of the American sociological review,
but occasionally,
you know,
you forget to put it that like little
card in the mail and your subscription
lapses.
Um,
so I'm just going to review for you the
findings of that study if you don't mind.
Um, and the, and the study on social
isolation made this incredible claim.
The article came out in,
in 2006 and it was by a team
of sociologists based to Duke.
Um, and the, the, the blockbuster finding
is the one that's on the screen there.
It said that, um, they,
they did a survey is based on a big
social survey and they looked at the
proportion of American adults
who said they have no confidence,
no close friends.
And it went from about one in 10 in 1985
which was fairly consistent with the
long literature of studies on,
on social connections
to one in four in 2004.
Now,
obviously Facebook wasn't really a thing
much of a thing in 2004 I don't think
it was a thing at all. Um, but,
so it's not Facebook that's
driving the story there, but the,
but the idea is that the big thing that
changed in our social world in that time
period is the internet. And
so the claim was, you know,
we're now more isolated than
we've ever been in there.
All these people who are disappearing and
the Internet must be the cause of that.
And, and when this article
came out, it was, you know,
this is a image from USA Today.
The authors were on the today show and
CNN and every publication in world did a
feature on them because that's
an incredible finding, right?
One in four Americans have no confidence.
And even that claim doesn't
come out of nowhere.
There's a long history in the social
sciences of looking at the fraying social
ties, uh, of modern life, right?
A longstanding claim that we have built
these big cities we built to kind of all
kinds of modern conveniences
and a mass society.
And out of that has come
a level of isolation and
disconnection that we've never
before established.
So these are among the best selling
books in the history of sociology and the
social sciences. Um, here on the other
side of the political spectrum, uh,
the American spectator,
a right wing publication on the
loneliness of American society.
Think very similar ideas.
More recently,
probably some of you have seen books like
bowling alone from Robert Putnam. Um,
Sherry Turkle,
I presume has been here to Google or to
the New York Google to talk about her
research on people being alone together.
More recently,
she's got a book about the
end of conversation. So this
is a very big idea, right?
And a couple of years ago when
I set out to write a book,
uh,
about the social trend,
I thought I would be contributing
to that conversation.
So when I sold the book for the book,
for this research project,
the working title was alone in America.
Okay. Which fits really nicely
into this tradition, right?
And so clearly it was about
to become a bestseller. Um,
all you need is the right title.
And as I started to do research,
I learned a bunch of amazing things that
really changed the way I think about
this issue.
And give me these things,
continue to give me pause when I
think about these issues today.
And I want to walk you
through some of them, right?
So imagine if you were going to write
a book called the loan in America,
it would have a really different mood.
I really different cover image.
Then they're going solo book,
right? It's going slowly.
You can see is a really different
idea. So how did I get there? Well,
this was the thing that made me want
to write this book in the first place.
I noticed what for social scientists
is a staggering social change, right?
So if any of you have ever been to a
meeting of sociologists are demographers,
when we discover something
like a percentage point
or two that's changed in a
population trends, we're high
fiving in the hallways, you know,
or like spiking the clicker at
the end of our talk. You know,
that's a huge accomplishment to make.
And the social sciences and you know,
strangely there's not,
had not been a lot of
discussion about this, this,
this staggering change that from from
1950 to 2014 the proportion of American
adults who are single or unmarried
goes from 22 to now about 50% right?
Half a slight.
A slight majority of American adults
are single today for the first time in
recorded history.
And the proportion of households that
have just one person has gone from 9% in
1952 a little under 30% today.
And these are major,
major demographic changes in how we live.
And I thought this should be exhibit
a and the story of how Americans have
become disconnected and lonely
and isolated. And in fact,
if you read a lot of research papers
from other social scientists and surely
lots of journalism, it is trotted out
as exhibit a for why we're so lonely.
Um, there are other ways to
represent this trend here.
You can just see the kind of steady rise
of Americans who are living alone over
time. Um, you know,
this is a kind of demographic cut of
who's living alone. It's interesting when,
when I started this project,
I had just written a book about a big
heat wave disaster in Chicago were
hundreds of people died and died alone.
And I thought the story of,
of living alone in the U s was really
primarily story of aging alone.
But it turns out that the largest group
of Americans who live alone are adults
between the ages of 35 and
64 and in recent decades,
the biggest spike in living alone has
come from this younger generation under
the age of 35. Right? Like
you get married later, um,
and you start a family much later.
So the way that you become an adult
for a rising generation there was to,
is to get a place of your own right
to get the hell out of your parents'
basement and get a place of your own.
So,
so even this chart was
really interesting to me.
It seemed like a more interesting story.
And I also learned what I was doing,
the research that whereas
up until about 1950, uh,
living alone was something that was most
common in big, sprawling western states.
Um, you know, in Nevada and
Wyoming and Montana by, uh,
2000 living alone had become
a very urban phenomenon.
I was most common in, in major
metropolitan areas. And you know,
in Manhattan where I live,
it's almost one and two households is a
one person household and San Francisco
is like 40%, you think,
okay, San Francisco, New
York, those are weird places.
They're not quite like America,
but look at this, you know,
Minneapolis, 43%, Denver,
40%, Seattle, 42%, Atlanta, 45%. I mean,
it really is far more pervasive.
The one person household than I had
understood and was actually far more
pervasive than most social scientists
had really understood before I did it.
So this rise of a single society
is a major force in the world.
So remember I talked about this in
terms of being alone in America at first
because my premise was that these were
people who are not just living alone,
but also alone much of the time
and more isolated, more lonely.
Um, I'm going to tell you about
the alone part in a second,
but I want to start by telling you like
when you're a social scientist and not a
politician, a or an eye, or look in
an ideological, um, column writer,
one of the great things is you get
to be wrong and you get to be wrong.
And then say, oh, I totally screwed
that up and I learned something.
And here at the end of the day,
I have a different idea about how
the world works. Then when I started,
that's what's about social research.
So let's start by how, how,
what a bad idea it was for me to
talk about this as alone in America.
Living alone is not at all
an American trend. In fact,
the United States is a laggard and not
a leader when it comes to being single.
Uh, we are way down on this list of
places that have a lot of living alone.
I don't know if you can read it.
It looks very, very small to me,
but the Scandinavian countries
are at the very top of the list.
A bunch of European
countries are above us.
Living alone is more common in Japan
than it is in the United States,
which is interesting given the kind of
family centric nature of that culture.
Living alone is more prominent
in Canada and I don't know why,
but just kind of irks me in general or
Canada ranks ahead of the United States
in anything. So that's always been
an annoying, uh, finding for me.
But say it again. There you go.
There you go. Flip it around.
Genius. We, when you kind
of need more thinking like
that and the next four years,
I think. Um, so, um, okay. So what
about this alone business? You know,
are we really alone? Okay. Yes, more
people are likely to live alone,
but I started doing
some research on my own.
I discovered some extraordinary
thing. So for instance, um,
it turns out that people who live alone
are actually more likely to spend time
with friends and neighbors
and people who are married.
They're more likely to go out at night
and spend time in bars or in restaurants
and cafes, uh, book talks and
we're likely to book talks. Um,
they are also more likely,
and this was a real surprise to me
to volunteer and civic organizations.
So that idea of like the selfish
single, the narcissist is not right. Um,
here's a shocker for you.
Um, uh, it turns out that um,
women who are single and live alone
are far more likely to participate,
significantly more likely to participate
in civic organizations than women who
are married with children.
Um, Tufts sociology, like I,
someone told me that there's research
showing that women who are married tend to
do more of the housework than their,
their spouses. Like more, you know,
they do more cleaning and more kink taking
care of the children and things like
that. I had exactly the same reaction.
You did like a can't be true.
There's no way that's right. But
apparently, apparently it is. Um,
and so women who are single actually I
have more time to engage in the world.
And you know, it's not to say that
raising children is not a civic duty.
It is of course,
but it's an interesting and surprising
finding this level of civic participation.
But also if you look historically at
patterns of informal social participation,
you find a story that's very different
than the, is Facebook making us lonely?
Uh, we've never been so lonely.
We've never been so isolated.
These patterns which show kind of overall
trends in spending time with relatives
or with friends or with neighbors or in
bars show that basically things haven't
changed all that much.
Uh,
over time we've had a modest decrease
in the amount of time that we with
neighbors,
but we've also had an uptick in the
amount of time that we spend with friends
who aren't from our neighborhood,
which is consistent with our understanding
of the way we form social ties right
now. Overall patterns of
social participation or just
about the same as they were
before for informal socializing.
Uh,
and the percentage of people who are,
who are really never social,
who never socializing a is
also a pretty stable. Um,
so remember that research study I told
you about the isolation in America? Well,
it turns out that the data
that that study drug drew upon,
we're flawed and inaccurate.
And now the, you know,
one of the authors of this paper,
the graduate student who did the real
data crunching on this has backed off from
the claim and says it's
not reliable. Um, uh,
it turns out though that this is what
my friends and I called the Great Zombie
finding of the social sciences.
Like,
no matter how often we all
kill the thing and say,
oh, no matter how often we say that,
it's, it's, it's not right. Uh, the, the,
you can't kill this study. You, you see,
like every time there's an article
about loneliness or social isolation,
a trend in American life,
you will get in the first few paragraphs
a citation to this study and serious
scholars do it all the time.
Journalists do it. It's a huge problem.
Um, but you can understand like why
that headline is so memorable. Um,
imagine if, um, you know,
when we put up findings
like the one you just saw,
the USA Today had a headline that said
Americans just about as lonely and
isolated is,
we've always been,
that would be a completely boring headline
that no one would ever read or pay
attention to. Um, it turns out that our
social life is much more interesting, um,
but also more stable than,
than people generally acknowledged.
So I don't think that that we can
events this claim right now. Um,
we can't show that there's been a real
spike in loneliness. In fact, the, the,
the main claim even empirically in the
Atlantic story about loneliness comes
from a study that the arp did have older
people who were in fact not even using
Facebook at the time. So the data
are really poor for this claim.
And that's not to say that,
that it's,
there's not potential for us to become
more lonely and more isolated given the
way that we use technologies.
But it hasn't happened yet. Um,
who we should need to be a
lot more somber about this.
So I had written this book about the
rise of single people in the world and I
did it with the penguin press
and a few weeks late, you know,
I guess months after the thing came out,
I got this call out of nowhere saying,
uh, you know, Eric, it's your editor.
I'm sorry to bother you.
I've got this kind of funny question.
Have you ever heard of this? A guy named
Aziz Ansari, and this is, you know,
2013 so he wasn't quite
the household name. Um,
but he wasn't expecting my response,
which was Aziz Ansari. He's my hero.
Um, cause it turns out, you know, I
had become a big as Ansari sorry fan.
And he said, oh, that's great
news because um, we really, uh,
we'd love to have you guys worked
together on a project. And I said, well,
what's the project
about? And he said, well,
let me explain and
actually why even better,
why you just come down here as
these are sitting in my office, uh,
and he wants to talk to you about it.
So I dropped my,
my things and raced over
there, uh, to go talk.
And here's Aziz his
account of the thing that,
that the problem that he was
trying to work through at the time.
You have a special out now that
everyone's talking about and a Aziz Ansari
buried alive. I understand you're
already working on your next special,
is that true?
Yeah. I voted you written the next hour
we're going to start touring it, uh,
next year. And um, yeah,
this one's about kind of a,
this new one that I'm working on is about
kind of what it means to be single and
this era. I think it's really
a frustrating time to be
a single person right now.
You know, I like the idea of being single
in theory, you know that's like, oh,
you meet a bunch of different people.
You get to know them when you
meet someone you really like.
You kind of pursue a deeper
thing that that sounds cool.
I would sign up for that,
but that's not,
we'll be in single is anymore now like
this is, this will be in single is now.
Hey, it was great meeting you. We
should get together sometime. Yeah,
they'd be great. Be in touch. All
right, cool. Bye. Hey, what's up?
She would grab a drink
tonight. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm with some friends in this
neighborhood. Oh cool. Be Down there soon.
Can't wait to see you. All right, cool.
Hey, what's up? We're almost there.
Shit, we just lab. Why? Why did you just,
why was on the way? Maybe get a
drink tomorrow. Tomorrow's perfect.
Texted him and make a plan. All
right, cool. Bye. Hey, what's up?
She grabbed those drinks tonight.
All drank way too much last night.
Going to stay in today.
That's not what was discussed yesterday.
You need a transcript of our conversation.
Scroll up on your phone.
Maybe we can meet up on Tuesday. Tuesday's
perfect. Texted him and make a plan.
All right, cool. Bye. Hey, what's up?
As Tuesdays we get together today,
Liz,
now all that garbage.
It's pretty much now,
a lot of times like you're a secretary
for this really shotty organization.
Scheduling the dumbest shit with the
flaky as people.
All right. So, so that was the, um, the,
the problem that is ease with struggling
with when I first met him, you know,
um, okay. So there are all these people
who were single today and diseases,
one of them and the culture has
really become confusing. Um,
it like once upon a time,
maybe it was easier to find romance.
Maybe it was a simpler process.
Now it seems really convoluted and as he's
wanting to know, you know, we'll, we'll,
what do we actually know about how the
search for romance has changed over time?
Um, what are some of the dilemmas
that people face today? And he said,
I've been looking for, um,
for research or to try,
he didn't actually read a lot of
social science and I just couldn't find
anything. So I just said, you know,
screw it. I'm going to do it myself. Um,
well maybe I'll do it myself. Maybe I'll
find a social scientist to do with me.
Um, and so we decided
to do it. And, you know,
it was a very interesting collaboration.
We had no idea what it
was going to be like.
It was a terrifying thing
for me because, um, you know,
I take my time pretty seriously,
my, like most scholars and, uh,
kind of cherish the ability I have to do
research and, and uh, on the one hand,
this is a tremendously
exciting opportunity to work
with someone who I think is
really a genius and entertaining and
insightful in ways that, you know,
the great comedians are. But then the
other time it was, on the other hand,
it was a little bit of a wild
ride to take. Um, but you know,
you only live once and how could I
say no? Um, and that was the question,
like which one of these
combinations was it going to be? Um,
so there's a bunch of things that,
that,
that we tried to do to get ourselves
oriented to the questions for the book.
I'm,
one of them was just trying to figure
out what the search for romance is aiming
towards these days.
And it's pretty clear that if you
look at our search for romance,
historically our expectations of what
we want have changed quite a bit,
even over the last several decades.
Um,
the way that we really establish this
or that I was able to establish this for
is ease. As I said, look, you know,
most of the people you hang out with are
in their twenties or early thirties, um,
and you have this particular
kind of world that you inhabit.
We're here in Manhattan right now.
Let's walk down a few blocks from
the village to the lower east side.
And let's go to an old folks home.
Let's go to a senior center and
gather a bunch of people together for
conversation, uh, and, and have them
tell us about how they met their spouse.
And he's, he's just like, oh, that
sounds like a really good idea,
but why on earth would a,
anyone ever come and talk to us?
They're not going to know who we are.
You know, they've got other stuff to do.
And I was like, no problem.
We can solve this donuts.
So we went and got boxes of donuts and
we showed up at the senior center and
everybody came for the conversation
and it was a great conversation,
a great way to recruit a sample.
And we started asking people to tell
us the story about how they met their
spouse. And one after the next
people would say, oh, well, you know,
I was 23 years old and I was living
with my parents and my older brother had
this friend and I knew that guy.
Like he'd spend a lot of time around the
family when I was a kid and you know,
we went out one day and he
seemed like a pretty good guy.
So we got married and there was
like, Oh wow, that's a crazy story.
And then what next one?
Oh, you know, there was a,
someone who lives in my building and I
know their family forever and I was 19
years old and I was living at home
and one for, uh, for a few times.
And we got married and we were
like trying to figure out, well,
this is an amazing thing. What's this
about? That seems really odd. And,
and people started explaining,
well, actually, you know,
the thing was that back then it wasn't
really legitimate for you to move out of
your parents' house,
especially if you were a woman.
If you weren't married and you really
want it to escape your parental control,
parental control. And this
was a great way to do it. Um,
like premarital sex is really frowned
upon. It's just no place to go.
And so getting married, uh, was something
that you did very early, uh, in life.
And it was also something
that you did very local.
And so we heard these conversations.
I said, you know, that rings a bell.
I remember these studies that I
had heard about in graduate school.
Let me go back and see. And it turns
out that in the 1930s and forties,
there was an industry in American
sociology of doing propinquity studies.
And sociologists would look at things
like the marriage records of 5,000
consecutive marriages in the city
of Philadelphia and see, you know,
who was marrying whom?
Just cause you had to put your address
for both the husband and the wife and the,
and the wedding certificate.
So this is one classic study
from a guy named James Broussard.
It came out I think in 1933
and it's extraordinary.
It shows that about, um, so this is,
this, this unfortunately you can't see,
but it's like around 12, 12% of
marriages in the city of Philadelphia.
This is just 5,000 straight marriage
records where people who lived in the same
building, okay, not related. Um,
about four and a half percent,
we're on the same block and
6% were within two blocks.
So it's almost one in four marriages.
And Philadelphia in 1932 were two between
two people who live within two blocks
of one another. You know, and
as easy as like, I don't even,
I wouldn't even want to go for coffee
with one of those Bozos who live within
two blocks of me, like let
alone, let alone get married.
And so something like 80% of all marriages
took place to people who lived within
20 blocks of one another in Philadelphia.
And the typical age of first marriage
around the time was something like 21 or
22 for women and 23 for men.
Right?
And when people were looking for what
the sociologist Andrew Cherlynn calls the
good enough spouse, they
wanted a good enough marriage,
like someone who was like,
they're there. They,
we're not an ax murderer.
It was basically their number one
characteristic and the number two,
it was like they knew
somebody in the family.
And you probably grew up around
that, right? So now, 2010,
um, yeah, you know,
5% of people in 2010 married
somebody who was a neighbor.
Um,
22% met someone who they met online,
married someone they met
online to already today.
A meeting online is the,
is the most common way that
Americans meet their spouses. Um,
people still met in, in bars and got
married. By the way, that's a tie.
If you're single, that's a terrible place
to meet someone to get married. Don't,
don't marry someone you met in a club,
please. So it's a really bad idea. Um,
uh, friends of friends, also very common,
but you could see just how much
the world has changed from,
from 1930 to 2010 and it's extraordinary
what this transformation is.
And, and, and, you know, and, and by the
way, that's, that's for straight couples.
For same sex couples, uh, the, the,
the use of the Internet is
off the charts, right? And,
and that was a kind of a wreck,
a very difficult situation.
If you grew up in a community where
there weren't a lot of out, uh, uh,
people interested in same
sex relationships, it was
very hard to find someone.
The Internet has completely changed
the game there, right? Uh, and, and,
and what's happening now is,
you know,
we're starting to see these trends
move into other areas and including,
it's like second marriages, um,
older people who are, uh, you know,
looking for kind of a second marriage or
third marriage after a divorce or a, uh,
they've become widows or widowers.
The Internet is really growing as a,
as a way to meet people.
But when people look to get married,
they're not just looking for
good enough spouse anymore.
Generally people in interviews will tell
you they're looking for a soul mate,
right? They're looking for someone
who's, who's like, they completes,
who completes them, uh, who with whom
they feel like this kind of deep, deep,
soulful connection that, that they
wouldn't otherwise have in life. Right?
And so not only do we think it's
okay to look for a soul mate,
that's what we should do. We're willing
to spend a very long time in that search,
right? So today we marry
later than ever. Historically,
the average age of first marriage is 26
or 27 for women and 28 or 29 for men in
urban communities like this one, the
average age of first marriage is over 30.
Right?
If you work at Google and you've got like
a 26 year old colleague who's getting
married 50 years ago, it'd
be like, that's amazing.
I can't believe it took you so long,
but congratulations. That's great news.
I hope you can still
get pregnant. And, and,
and now if you have a 26 year olds
gay man, he's like, are you crazy?
What are you doing? You know, you
have to live a little bit, you know,
you don't even know who
you're going to be yet. Right.
And actually it turns out that,
um,
we know that if you get
married before the age of 25,
you are far more likely to get divorced.
And if you get married after,
and we have the sense that by kind of
growing up as a, as a single person,
you're in a better position to have a
stable relationship over time and the date
of bare that out a little bit.
So,
so one big change is we have a
different expectation, right?
We're not looking for,
we're not looking for a good enough
marriages were looking for soul mates. Um,
that's a very hard search.
It can take a very long time,
but the potential payoff can be very high.
Another big change is obviously
about the way that we do that search.
And when I showed you some slides that
suggested how much the Internet has
become a part of this,
but one of the, the, um,
things that disease was convinced of
and that was born out by the research we
did over a couple of years,
is that being single is very different
in a world that where most of us live a
lot of our lives in these machines,
right?
Anyone here happen to be
carrying a phone with them today?
Anybody have a phone with them?
Um, w we do, of course you're,
you're the only honest person in the room.
Um, we're all carrying phones with us.
We all carry phones with us wherever we
go. If we don't have our phones with us,
we feel really weird. Like
someone has, you know,
like taking our oxygen away and um,
and that's changed the way that we,
that we live, right? We,
we participate in this face to face world
occasionally like speaking at Google
and this series is amazing
cause they'd be like, okay,
like there's gonna be like
30 or 40 people at your talk,
but there'll be 3000 people watching
you from their desks. I'd be like, oh,
that's in New York.
That makes a lot of sense.
Like it's too bad they
can't be there. Like, no,
like in the next room since we've weird
does actually see you face to face.
So Hi guys, watching on your screens
right now. There's plenty of seats.
You guys are all welcome
to come and join us.
So we spend a lot of
our time on our phones.
And what that means is that
whereas, you know, not long ago,
if you wanted to meet somebody,
you would go to like a bar or to a party,
like friends of friends,
you'd be set up on a date.
And those things happen by the way.
Like some people would do
that at nine in the morning,
but most of us did that after
eight at night. You know,
like you'd go out and those,
like I remember like when I was in
college Thursday or Friday night,
you would walk out and you would all go
to like a physical party together and
you'd hope that that person who was in
your history class, it was really cute,
would show up and maybe even think like,
oh maybe I know she's going to come
to that party and you didn't have cell
phones. So you just hope that she was
there and like the same hour block.
And if not,
you'd spend like the whole night walking
around campus hoping you'd bump into
each other.
Right.
And now it's like you would never do that
because you would just text the person
and find out if they were there.
But more importantly,
for people who aren't on college campuses,
you're basically carrying a single's
bar in your pocket all the time,
right? So if you're here and you
have a phone and you're single,
and I'm sure there's at least one of you
like that here, chances are, you know,
you've got Tinder on your phone,
right? You've got bumble in your phone,
you've got Okcupid in your phone.
If you're really serious about this,
you've got matching your
phone. You're like, I'm going
to do that this year. 2017.
I'm going to go from match.com I'm
going to make a commitment. Um,
and that really changes the dynamics.
It means that like at any given moment,
you have access to thousands of potential
partners and you could be flirting
with them.
You can be just kind of playing around
like we were doing the research.
Tinder had just come out and nobody wanted
to admit that they're actually trying
to meet people on
Tinder. They're like, oh,
I just did it as it was my friends
kind of for a laugh, which is really,
if we all thought it was funny,
but you know,
everybody was starting to date on Tinder.
Um, and this is really challenging.
Like it's hard to do the thing you're
supposed to be doing at any given time
because you are living with a
single's bar in your pocket, right?
That's a very tough situation.
What that also means is you're
looking for your soul mate.
You've got thousands of options and uh,
people every day are presented
with what Barry Schwartz,
the psychologist talks about is the
paradox of choice, right? Um, you know,
you've got all these possibilities
and it turns out it's really,
really difficult to live with
enormous numbers of options there.
Maximizers in the world who are
always looking for the best thing.
And if we're looking for love,
we're probably looking at,
we're probably maximizers
most of the time.
And then they're satisfied writers who
were just like looking for the good
enough marriage, but they're not,
a lot of those satisfies sirs.
And the problem is now,
if you are looking for the best
relationship and you have Tinder,
the the comparisons can never stop.
Right?
And so what's so difficult about
choice Schwartz told us is, you know,
first of all, when you
have a lot of options, um,
it's difficult to know what it is that
you really care about. You know, what,
what should really mattered
to you and how do you,
how do you make a selection for a
particular person? But then also,
let's say I've gone through like 150
people on Tinder and I've swiped right and
she swiped right too.
And we make the connection and then
we go and meet each other within five
minutes. I'm like, oh, is that really
the right person? Because there are one,
you know, 999 other people who
are there, you know, tonight.
And if I,
if like I managed to run to the bathroom
and like swipe right again and see.
So there's problem with people not
feeling good about the choices they made
because they have regret about
the people they've overlooked.
And that's an enormous challenge
for people who are dating today. Um,
then there are all kinds of
interactional dilemmas, um,
that happened when people are trying
to find romance through machines. Um,
you know, the [inaudible], anybody here
ever had this conversation with a friend?
Like
you meet somebody online and,
or your friend meet someone online.
Let's just talk about in terms of
friends and they're like, oh, uh,
I liked them and ask them out,
but I don't know what the right messages.
And the person's like, oh, it
doesn't matter what you write.
Like if they like your picture,
they're going to like you.
If they're like your picture,
It doesn't matter what you,
what you texts, you know,
don't even worry about the messaging.
And anyone heard a version of that story?
Yes, yes, yes. Okay. Thank you.
Google is still alive.
Um, okay. So as these,
and I want it to get like the definitive
scientific answer to this question of
does it actually matter what you text
someone or is it really just about the
pictures? Like, we know the pictures
are really important. So, um,
we realize that every night
when disease is doing standup,
he was talking to thousands of
people and it was a great way to have
conversations about, you know,
people's experiences in the world.
We could kind of use them as like massive
social experiments and interviews and
focus groups. So, um,
I want to read you a quick passage from
the book and if you can just like try to
imagine me reading this in diseases,
voice will be a much funnier. Okay.
So he says at this particular show,
I was speaking with Rachel who had met
a guy and a good friend's wedding as it
happened.
The guy was also a friend of her sisters.
So he had a pretty good shot at a
first date with her. She was single,
she was interested. All he had to
do was send her a simple message,
introducing himself and asking her to
do something. Here's what happened.
He sends his first message,
Hi Rachel. Exclamation point.
Since I never got a chance to ask you
to dance at Marissa and Chris's wedding
parentheses, I'm Chris, his
old roommate from Purdue. Dot.
Dot. Dot. And parenthesis,
he and your sister gave me your number.
I wanted to say hi and sort of
texty introduced myself. Haha.
Smiley face. Hope you had a great
weekend. Hope to chat with you soon.
As soon as I said texty it was clear
that no one sitting in the 3,600 seats,
Chicago theater, whatever. Fuck
this dude in a million years.
Texty for whatever reason
seem to be unequivocally
disgusting to every one of us
there. He might as well
have added, by the way,
I have a really disgusting next level
STD. Haha Smiley face. But for real,
I do.
Rachel wrote back 10 minutes later by the,
I recognize this is probably the
end of the [inaudible] Google uh,
seminar series here. So, uh, it is what
it is. It was good while it lasted.
Hey, exclamation point.
Great to meet you too.
Currently enjoying my birthday
weekend with lots of good Mexican food
parentheses. It happens when
your birthday is Cinco de Mayo.
Hope you had a great weekend too.
He wrote back shortly. I totally,
there's like eight owes here. I totally
realized upon reading my last message,
I didn't include my name.
I will smiley face for company on
yellows as well and totally right.
Digging on that Cinco de Mayo theme,
Rachel never met will
after a few messages of this nature,
Rachel stopped responding. None
of us know, well he may be a kind,
handsome man with a heart of gold,
but all we have to go on and it's those
messages and those messages if shaped in
our minds, a very dorky
terrifyingly Caucasian Weirdo.
Yes, it matters what you text
now. Um, it matters what you text,
but it's hard still to know
what is appropriate to tax
and what isn't it because
our norms about what you can communicate
via text message are changing very
rapidly and things,
things that seem really
strange to us today, you know,
might soon be very normal.
Um, and, and in fact, like even,
even as we did the interviews for the
book with people of different generations,
we heard really funny things.
Like, you know, when we started,
we ask these questions. Like
I said, I have this key,
is it okay to break up with
somebody by texts, you know,
can you break up his own by text?
And we talked to people who are in their
late twenties I'd be like, oh, no way.
You know that, that that is, I'm not,
I know I'm not 30 yet, but still,
that is a horrible thing to
do to a person, you know,
like breaking off is really
painful and you know,
you owe it to that person to be there
face to face and just to say what you
think and to have that physical
interaction with someone.
Like I would never do that.
And we talked to people who are like in
their late or early twenties and they'd
say, you know, I know that you
shouldn't break up with somebody by tax.
I mean it's a shitty thing to
do. But honestly, like yes,
yes I do. And we're like,
we do everything by text.
So I figure we might as well,
like I asked her out by text, the
first time's fine. So yes, I do it.
I don't feel good about it.
I know it's not right. Um,
but I do it and we talked to like,
people in their late teens,
you know, like freshmen in college
and be like, Oh my God is he is Eric.
I wish someone would
break up with me by tax.
Like all I want in life is somebody
to break up with him via tax.
Like there's this guy I was seeing for
months and I haven't heard from him in
forever and I think we're not
going out anymore, but I, you know,
I don't really know
because he doesn't respond.
So if you just write me a text message
and say it's over, it would be amazing.
So we're even seeing this like change
from these small kind of parts inside
generations over time.
Right. The overall kind of threading
through all of this is this question of,
you know, returned back to this Facebook
issue of this Facebook make us lonely.
It doesn't make us lonely. But, um,
now that we do spend so much of our time
interacting with people digitally and
now that our social worlds of expanded
so that we interact with people who we
don't know all that well
personally, maybe we have, um,
text-based relationships or
they're part of a social circle,
their friends or friends of friends,
but they're still there. Um,
does it make it easier for us to
treat them as bubbles on a screen?
Right. And not as people. And I don't
think we've settled the, this question,
but I think it, it really is an
interesting question. You know, what,
what is the evolving nature of social
norms in a world where we're communicating
with different kinds of people who are,
you know, part of our network in some way.
Um, but not, you know, core
intimate partners. Okay.
Let me wrap up.
Um,
I always feel like I should provide
some public service at the end of these
talks. Um, so you know, people
often want to know like, okay,
you did all that research
is very interesting. Uh,
appreciate that a ton of time when you
read from the Book and God is he his
voice in there? Cause I actually got
a genuine laugh in that moment. Um,
but is there anything that you learned
in the course of this project that can
actually help me as a single
person or my cousin? Um,
and so I've got three things
I'd like to close with today.
Three short pieces of advice if you're
interested anyone that'd be helpful just
to get to the three. Kind of like dating
tips from all this occasionally. Okay.
We've got three, three, three dating
tips that happy to come back on, uh,
on Valentine's Day in a few
weeks. Um, okay. Number one.
First a dating tip comes from, um, uh,
actually comes from Robb Willer who's a
sociologist and social psychologist at
Stanford. If he hasn't come
here, cliff, to give a talk,
you should get him over here. He's a
great, great guy, amazing speaker. Um,
and rob was helping us with some
of the, um, uh, analysis he's,
he does to these terrific social
experiments. But then actually what,
what rob wound up helping us with the
most came from his own life and he was
like, oh well one of the problems with,
with dating these days is like, you,
you don't want to go on these
really boring ass first dates.
Everybody online does like the,
they do this boring ass first dates.
And the reason is that,
um,
can you raise your hand if you've ever
gone on an online date in this room?
Could you mind, I know where to workplace.
That's a little bit awkward. Okay. So, so,
um, okay. So if you ever go
on a first date with someone
you met online, you know,
the problem is you don't want to
overinvest in the first, right.
Cause this stranger and we
know that they're like five
years older and 25 pounds
heavier than they look in their
photograph. Right? And so,
so nobody really wants to overinvest
it's not like you have a first date,
you know,
we're going to men Raisa and then I
rented a sailboat and we're going to do a
cruise.
But you never do that.
But you also don't want to like go
to Starbucks and have a latte because
everything we know about research on
dating says like our experiences and other
person is contextual, right? And
so the environment really matters.
And if like you're sitting in
a Starbucks having a Latte, um,
it's going to be a really boring first
day you're going to do a resume exchange
and you're like, I don't know. She wasn't
that interesting. Um, it was just, I just,
there was no spark there.
So Rob said, oh, the,
the first thing that people do wrong
and what you should try to do if you're
dating is you need to,
you need to follow the monster
truck rally theory of first dates.
And that is every first day it should
be in some place that's like super
interesting and kind of quirky and
it's going to make you laugh kind of no
matter what you're doing.
And it should be kind of surprising and
kind of fun monster truck rallies he
likes because especially for like
the overeducated tech, you know,
silicon valley people,
you know,
you probably don't spend a lot
of time at monster truck rallies.
But if someone said like, Hey, let's go
to a monster truck rally, you'd be like,
Whoa, that seems like a really interesting
and fun idea we're going to do it.
And it's like the quality of the whole
interaction and the quality of the
evening is going to be really great.
And so you don't have to go
to a monster truck rally,
but the idea is like for your first date,
do something that's like you always
really wanted to do on your own,
but you just don't have enough time and
use the date as an excuse to go do that
fun thing with another person. It makes
sense. Okay. That's tip number one.
Okay. Now this one, you probably,
you probably studied this in your um,
social science classes in
college or graduate school.
You probably familiar with the flow,
right?
A theory of acquired likability
through repetition. You.
You remember that one now? Okay, fine.
Um,
uh,
at the end of this talk I want you to
resubscribe to the American Sociological
Review and review your psychology notes
from, from college. Okay. The flow ride,
a theory of acquired likeability through
repetition is basically tells us that
in the end people are pretty
much like flo rider songs,
which is you hear them the first
time you're like, I don't know,
I've heard that song. I don't know
this. The flow riders has same song.
It's not that interesting. Ah, I
don't need another one of these.
But then if you keep listening to
the flow rider song again and again,
you're like, oh my God, Flo rider,
you are amazing. I love that song.
It turns out we have very
similar responses to people
that if you have like a
second date,
a third date,
the things that are
specific and interesting and
distinctive about people are
not actually the what they look like.
It's,
there are things that come
out in interactions over time.
And the big mistake that data is
generally make is they tend to overvalue
superficial things on the first date.
Like hotness and,
and, and undervalue things that, right?
Because we all know that that kind of the,
the temperature of the hotness is
going to decrease no matter what.
No matter who it is that you're
dating. Right. And we probably,
everyone in this room wants like dated
someone who they thought was way more
attractive than them and they're like,
I can't believe I'm actually dating her.
And then like on the third
day, like, oh my God,
I have nothing to say to this person.
Right?
So we tend to overvalue hotness and
we tend to undervalue the things that
actually really matter to us
over time and in relationships.
And those are things that tend to
come out over repeated exposure and
interactions, right? Which not to
say like attraction doesn't matter.
Of course in traction matters,
there's a baseline that you have to hit,
but there are a lot of people
who are like, I dunno, she
seemed pretty cool. Yeah.
If she,
I guess she was pretty attractive.
There just wasn't that spark on the first
time. You're like, what'd you do? Oh,
we were at a bowling alley
bowling. That sounds so fun. Oh No.
We were in the lounge having a coke.
You know,
you're never going to fall in love with
someone in a bowling alley lounge on a
first date over coke. It was a bad way to
fall in love. So give someone a chance.
That's the second one.
And then the third one,
this might be the most practical
thing. Um, I want to leave you with,
so there's another kind of dilemma and
problem that people have in a world where
we all, a lot of our relationships
are online and that is like, okay,
you start dating somebody
or with them for a while.
You build up this relationship,
you have all these friends in common,
you not only share experiences together,
you now share phone world
and a digital life together.
Like you posting pictures of her and him,
they're all over it.
You're all over Instagram and Facebook,
that your lives are totally intertwined.
And then he break up and
now you've got this problem,
which is that like you can't get rid of
this person from your history and you
want to go back and like look
at the picture of vacation
pictures or pictures of
yourself at party, see like the
friends or the experiences you had.
But every time you do it, you have
a photograph of your acts with you.
And so as these, and I found a great
strategy for dealing with this, uh,
it's just called [inaudible] and your ex.
And what that means is it doesn't
have to be Beyonce, by the way.
You can do this with Sonia
Sotomayor. Um, you could do it with,
you could choose Rick Perry. Uh, there's
any number of people you could do.
Basically you want to pick a,
a fairly well known person and just get
an image of their face and just paste it
over the image of your acts all over
the Internet and that will solve all of
your problems. So thank you very much. Um,
I really enjoyed the conversation.
I hope that was useful.
Hi. So, um, yeah,
I was really light in to hear
about how your findings disproved,
like that really popular study
that you said it was unfounded,
that people are actually lonelier now
than before about that or the study that
that showed that people were looking.
Yeah,
it kind of like brought to my mind this
quote that got circulated shortly after
the death of Robin Williams,
which I think I'm going to misquote it,
but it's this phenomenon
of the worst thing is,
and to be alone but is to be around
people who make you feel alone.
So I guess from your studies,
how do you,
that like technology has contributed
to that feeling and like what do you
actually call that? Yeah, so that's a
really interesting question. So, um,
there is this issue that's a little bit
related to the problem of choice that I
brought up before.
Uh,
and that is that many people today find
it very difficult to be where they are.
So
think about the last hour that
we've spent together. You know, now,
um,
it's very hard for most people to spend
an hour without checking their phone to
see what's happened. Did anybody check
your phone in the last hour? Come on.
This is the greatest hour of my life then.
I mean,
everybody checks their phone
all the time. And you know, I,
I know like I've don't take it personally
that you checked your phone in the
last hour.
We are hooked on these things.
We were looking for this new stimulation,
right?
We wondering what's going on in our
personal life and our home life.
Um, w w who won the soccer game. Uh,
there's all sorts of information
that we could be getting at any time,
which is actually generally
not all that urgent,
but were somehow in this cultural
moment where not everyone,
but a lot of us are kind of hungry
for the next new burst of information.
Like we want that adrenaline rush,
that endorphin kick that we're going
to get from getting the new thing.
And so we're constantly
failing to appreciate the
place we're in and the people
we're with.
And what I oftentimes think now is like
unless you are sitting directly across
to or next to a person you have met in
the last three weeks and are currently in
the process of falling
deeply in love with,
there's almost no thing that you're going
to be doing that's going to completely
distract you from like the buzzing noises
you're phone is making in your pocket.
Right? It's very hard for people
to focus on where they are.
And so what,
you know,
what happens is it becomes very easy
to degrade the quality of everyday
interactions and to take your
relationships for granted. And I do,
I do worry about that.
So that's not exactly kind of
the loneliness of being alone.
It's a different kind of experience. Now,
interestingly, that doesn't show up on,
uh, surveys of how lonely people are, the
best measures we have of for loneliness.
Don't tap into that.
But I do think that that's a phenomenon
that that's worth paying attention to.
And I'll tell you something from the
going solo project that was very powerful
to me.
Um,
so many people I interviewed who had
lived with someone and who then, uh,
you know, get separated and became
single and they've done their own, said,
you know,
my friends are always worried about me.
They asked me if I'm lonely
and what I tell them is yes,
there are moments of real pain when I'm
home by myself single and thinking about
what my future is going to be like.
But I'll tell you the truth.
There's nothing than a bad relationship.
There's nothing lonelier than
living with the wrong person.
That is very true. Okay. Eric,
thanks so much for coming.
Um, so you brought up the topic of, um,
now we're more searching for our
soul mate other than just a spouse.
That's good enough. Um, and I
noticed that even now that we're, uh,
some people even find that
soul is not good enough.
They want something more than saw
me. Well, what's that twin flame?
What twin flame. Oh, that's so weird. It's
a new thing. Yeah. It's like, so may plus.
Plus, are there actually any
research saying that finding
your soul mate actually
makes you happier? Because I'm very
skeptical about, uh, oh no, no,
there's no research like that. No, I mean
there really isn't. And so, so it's not,
it's not as if,
you know,
what I'm reporting to you is that
in fact people find their soulmates.
Um,
and we know that if you find your soulmate
and match on all the key criteria of
like what constitutes a soul, then
you'll be okay. You'll be happy. I mean,
we don't have that, right. So people are
optimizing for a random set of things.
And one thing we do know is that,
um,
we're terrible at knowing what it
is that we want and another person.
And what the reason we know this is
because of all the great data that we get
from, um, from dating sites
where people, you know,
like you go on match.com and you say like,
here are the five things I'm looking
for. You know, like I want a blonde,
a woman who has a phd from an Ivy
League school in the natural sciences,
not the social sciences,
right?
And she has to like skiing and be pro
choice and then like you like turn out
that if you, if you look at what
that person is actually choosing,
like who is that person asking out?
Right?
They're like tall brunettes who grew
up in the south and have a high school
degree, right? And like volleyball
and vote for Republicans.
And it turns out that that like we're
just really shitty it knowing what it is
that makes us happy.
And so,
so like the kind of research that
you're asking for of like how, you know,
how are we actually matching is
really hard to come by. That said,
um, oh and I should say
one other thing. Uh,
there's actually a really interesting
research on arranged marriages because as
these parents had an arranged marriage
and we talked about this a lot,
like we did interviews with them when
we looked into the research on arranged
marriages.
Um,
like at some point we were
sitting together doing
research and I start cracking
up because it's easy to
just told me how his,
his father met his wife and
married his wife were found,
has found his wife and his story,
it was like he,
his parents decided it was
time for him to get married.
They like introduce them to
one woman and she was too tall.
And then they introduced them to the
woman who became his wife and she was,
it was like the right,
that was the right decision.
And it occurred to me that actually like
as he spends more time trying to figure
out where to get a Taco,
then his father spent figuring out who,
which was the right woman to marry.
Like if you ever wanted to eat
with Aziz is incredibly difficult.
Like he's totally an optimizer
and maximizer and he does
like enormous amounts
research on everything because why would
you ever want to have the second best
Taco in the East village? Um, and
that can be really difficult. But his,
but his step father or his father went
through this like pretty simple process.
And it turns out with her and arranged
marriages, there's this idea like,
you know, when the marriage begins,
there's kind of like a simmer,
like just a little bit of heat.
And then over the course of
time in successful marriages,
you kind of build up to
the boil and the intimacy.
And actually the record on arranged
marriage is pretty strong in terms of
longevity compare and,
and people's feelings about the quality
of the marriage compared to our system
of like marrying the person you want to
marry by choice after having search for
your soulmate. So that, I think there's
really, really good reason to be,
to be skeptical, you know,
of that. But what we do know,
I was gonna say that said is that there
does seem to be some value in waiting
until later in life to get married.
And we do know that there's a lot
of volatility in people's, you know,
formative years,
both in terms of your life where you know
where you are and what you're going to
do and in terms of your character
development. And so, you know,
people who marry younger without having
gone through that search are just more
likely to have the relationships burnout.
So that was a somewhat of noxious and
long winded answer to your really smart
question. So my question,
um, focuses on cohabitation.
So the,
you know,
the fulfillment of happiness when you're
living with someone kind of depends on
like your level of sloppiness. Can the
other person cook, did they clean up?
You know, like all those things they
got to be biographical about this.
But from what I understand,
cleaning up after yourself. Yeah. So my,
my question is what's the research
or your, if there isn't research,
what's your personal opinion on,
you know,
our couples more successful if
they live together or apart?
Let's do you know, people who might
have different houses or apartments,
but they're married for
example. Yeah, I don't,
I don't know this debate as
much as I should probably.
I have a memory of reading studies
showing that actually there was a
relationship between cohabitation
and separation down the road,
that people were more likely to ultimately
divorce if they cohabitated before
marriage.
But that was just like a
simple correlation and then
it turns out if you tease,
tease it out, there was something about
the composition of the population,
like people who are more likely to live
together first were also more likely to
be in a population of people get
divorced. So to be honest, I don't,
I can't give you like the state
of the art finding on that,
but there's definitely a lot of
research on it. Um, definitely not.
Definitely not writing about that issue.
Um,
because it would be weird because I,
okay so I'm married,
I want to be clear about that.
Which was very difficult for me when I
was doing the going solo book cause I was
like inadvertently became this
person who like Eric Klinenberg.
We'll talk about the joys of singlehood,
which is not like that.
What I was not what I was going for,
but I wound up like writing this book
about how actually people who live alone
and I didn't even, you know, like
they're very social, they tended to like,
turns out the happiness levels
are much higher than we thought.
And then so I would get invited to
all these like singles, you know,
celebrate single. And my
poor wife was like, you know,
at first I thought this was like,
you're kind of escape fantasy book and
now I'm getting a little bit worried
about this, this project. And then
I started writing a book, you know,
about how young people
like hook up basically.
And that was spacious.
And so if I'm like,
yeah. And then my wife and I did
cohabitate before we got married.
So if I got really deep
into that question, she,
you know, she probably already
has a lot of doubts to begin with.
So the thing is a bad idea.
Yeah. I'm not going to do that,
but thanks for the suggestion.
Uh, so if you learn a lot more
about yourself as you grow up, uh,
and you're supposed to wait, you
till you get older as you marry, uh,
w what are you supposed
to do in the meantime?
Like I just graduated from college. I
just like told him my thumbs for 14 or 17.
Know this guy who's sitting next to
you? You guys ever met? No, he's, look,
yeah cause you're looking at here like
what the fuck are you talking
about? What I use? Are you serious?
No bike Blake. Shit, you're single in
the bay area and you work at Google.
What do you mean what are you supposed to
be doing in the next day? No, no, but, but
you guys talk after this.
He's going to tell you where to go.
Well wake, should you date
people seriously? Like you
know, like the idea of like,
should you be in your long plus
relationships or should you be,
you know, trying out more. I don't know.
I mean just kind of curious
what the research says.
I'm going to let you know what I have
decided to do. I'm just going to have put,
like,
I'm going to work in one of these private
offices after the talk and I'm just
going to take you like one at a time.
Like I kind of like the haircut
truck you guys have on campus.
I'd be like a relationship
adviser and you can just come,
you have to pay for the haircuts
here, right? So like the Tacos,
the Tacos are free, but you got to pay
for the haircut. So you'll probably,
I'm going to charge for these sessions,
but you could come. No, I look,
I think there's value in being in
relationships and you know, if you meet,
if you're,
if you meet someone who is,
you have a wonderful connection with
and um, you're, it really gels and you,
you know, it's like the right thing.
I'm not trying to say, you know, it's,
that's a crazy thing, right? Like I,
I'm a social scientist and I'm thinking
about large population samples and I'm
thinking probabilistically, right? So, in
your case of one person, you, you know,
you,
you're going to know what's right for you,
better than a sociologist who's looking
at big populations. Um, you know,
that said, um, uh, you
know, I think there's,
there's lots of value in
being in relationships.
There's lots of value and having
intimate experiences with someone else.
There's no rush to get married,
certainly in a rush to get married
and have children. Um, you know,
once you start to in these parts of your
life that things get difficult and if
you wind up changing in ways that were
unpredictable, um, you know, you're,
you find that you're, you're constrained.
And it's interesting like this,
this is really a deep thing about the
cultural situation we find ourselves in.
Um,
since the late 19th century,
there has been a concept in sociology
that I like quite a lot called the cult of
the individual.
And it refers to the way in
modern life that we have come to,
to value. Uh, the, the what's good for me,
what's good for the individual
as opposed to what's good,
what's good for the collective
that I'm a part of. Right.
And there's kind of a famous line
about, you know, w w why would,
why would a family and trust something
as important as marriage to, uh,
like other people getting married?
The marriage is not about two people.
When two people get married, it's
a, it's a, you know, it's a family.
It's a family event. It's
structures, groups of people.
Why would you let two young, stupid people
make a decision like that? Right? So,
so what's happened over time is that
our sense that our behavior should be
oriented towards optimizing
the group experience,
right? The group wellbeing
has been replaced by a notion
that our behavior should
optimize our individual condition.
Right?
It used to be the case that if you were
in a bad marriage and you were really
unhappy and you want it to get divorced,
not very long ago,
you would have to justify to your friends,
into your family this decision to get
divorced. This was the wrong thing to do.
But now if you're in a bad
marriage and you're really unhappy,
you'll have to justify it to your friends
and family, why you should stay in it.
Because our notion is like if you as an
individual aren't fulfilled and getting
what you need than it is wrong for you to
be in that situation. So our, you know,
our values have really shifted on this.
Um,
and so the,
you know,
that's when we talk about like don't put
yourself in a binding situation that,
um, is going to be difficult for you
down the line depending on who developed.
That's it.
I just want to call attention to my
own response to what you're saying,
which is like,
that is rooted in a very specific
cultural understanding of what constitutes
good behavior in a good life. And
it is quite remarkable. I, you know,
I've found throughout these projects,
I've done the extent to which our sense
of what's good ethical behavior is
rooted in our commitment to ourselves
as individuals, as the prime actors.
So that was a great way for me to
dodge the substance of your question.
Well, I'm saying something, you
know, marginally interesting. Okay,
final question. So, uh,
what you'll be writing about next
and who you hope that call is from.
So you got to meet a zs. You didn't know
that he was curious about this topic.
If there's anybody else that you'd
like to partner with, who would it?
Oh Wow. So I'm writing now book about
what I call social infrastructure.
And those are the places and,
um,
institutions that shape the way we
interact and actually, um, plead a Google.
One of the things I really want to
study is, um, workplaces and how, um,
how can you design a, a
workplace so that you, um,
facilitate interactions and promote
cohesion and connection. Um,
and while I'm here in the bay area,
I'd really like to know
more about what Google does.
So if anyone here happens to work at
Google or you're connected to anyone who
works at Google and you could help me,
I would really appreciate that. Uh,
um,
I'll even,
I'll give you back all of my speaker's
fee speaking fee for today is the lecture.
I will refund 100% of my
speaker's fee, um, for, for that,
uh, information. So I would
love to, I actually love to
learn more about Google, um,
and writing that book.
And who would I be unable to say no to
if they called me and asked if I could
write a book with them?
I don't,
I haven't even thought about that
question. Can I get back to you on that?
Sergey and Larry,
now those chomps,
what do they know? Um, now, um, I
don't know. I don't know. I got,
it's such a good question. Dammit. I
wish I knew the answer to that question.
Continue that. I'm going to think
about it. Taking suggestions. Uh,
Hu [inaudible] Daniel Conaman.
Oh yeah,
he's got a new book
about him already though.
It's probably better than what I
could do a confirming. Say that again.
Nick Offerman, you continue the
parks and directories. Actually,
I did get a call from,
um,
key and peels agents right after the book
came and asked me if I would come and
talk to them.
And then I got really scared that I
would just become known as that social
scientists who writes with
Comedians, uh, and I didn't do it.
So plus,
as you can all tell,
like what really happened to me as I
developed this like fantasy that I too
would someday become a comedian and find
a social scientist to write with me. Um,
but I think we're a long, long way
from that happy day. So are we done?
[inaudible] thank you.
[inaudible].